The perception of intelligence is extremely important in human evolution,
and as a result, pretty important to your life.
Psychology shows that in text, when a middle initial is used,
there are positive evaluations of a person's intellect and abilities.
Middle initials are generally saved for more formal contexts like John F Kennedy.
One study asked participants to choose academic team partners,
and those with middle initials were more likely to be chosen.
Middle initial equals increased perceived status.
Hey! Reservation for Lilly, please?
No, I don't see it.
So (sorry)
Uh, Lilly Singh?
No, It's a bank ambassador golf tournament
We're so swamped
What about Lilly S. Singh
*Slowed down* Oh my god
Let her in
It has been found that when something seems
more "scientific", it has a greater power to persuade
In a study,
67% of participants believed a specific
piece of information without a graph but
if a graph was added then ninety-six
percent of the participants believed it
even though it was the same information
OMG we should totally watch Magic Mike
it got 80 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
I don't know about dude dancing. I don't think that's for me
No, yeah me neither. That's gross
Did I mention it got a 80% on Rotten Tomatoes
Oh, okay yeah yeah
Lilly, why don't you try a new science fact for us?
No, I don't know anything about science. I don't want to seem stupid
No, you just have to speak expressively
and people will believe you
It's scientific fact
Really?!
Waddup everyone! It's your girl, Superwoman!
When two people have the same things to say
one modulates their speak and
keeps pauses to a minimum
they come across as more knowledgeable
In a recent study
participants were asked to present to a hypothetical employer
and those who use various pitches, tones and volumes
were perceived as more thoughtful, intelligent and
left a better overall impression
Was that okay? I have no idea what I just said
There's actually a correlation between
what a university professor wears
and how the students learn
In fact, if the instructors wear more formal attire
the students are less likely to misbehave
Stereotypes play a big role in how people perceive you
and there's a pretty big stereotype that
smart people wear glasses
In fact, studies even show that those people who wear glasses
are perceived as more intelligent
I just finished the most fascinating article about ISIS
and the impact it's having on Lebanon borders
I mean, will the sanctions work?
Have you read it?
Um, yes, obviously
I am fully aware of all issues related to the Middle East
Are you sure you've actually read it?
Yes!
OMG! You're so smart!
You definitely have.
To be honest I don't fully understand the Iran deal
The ability to accurately assess someone else's intelligence
is of great evolutionary importance
You don't want to mate with a dummy
Studies have found that when people observe headshots
the ones that are rated as highly intelligent
are more often smiling
so show them pearly whites
I hope we're making a good impression
I really want her to think that we're smart
Keep smiling
She's turning around!
ASAP science is so smart
They even look intelligent in real life
She looked!
Alcohol consumption and cognitive impairment go together
Known as the imbibing idiot by a study
found that managers perceive candidates to be less
intelligent if they ordered a wine over a soda
Another study found that those
who are actually just holding alcoholic beverages
were perceived to be less intelligent than those who were not
Hey, boo
Where you from?
I'm from Toronto but I'm just visiting LA
Oh, just visiting
Ok, what kind of girls you into
Well, I'm scientists so I really like smart girls
(record scratch)
Oh (throws cup away)
So weird because just happen to be one of those smart girls
Did you know?
The mitochondria is the powerhouse of the cell
Thanks for watching!
We hope you liked that video
Make sure to subscribe to Lilly's amazing channel
She makes awesome comedy, hilarious videos
We'll put the links in the description to that
Thank you so much for being here